[Music]
what do you suppose he's thinking about
right now it gets very minute
[Music]
back in 7th or 8th grade I have got a
skateboard yeah I practiced on that
skateboard quite a bit I was able to
eventually do an ollie and that took a
lot of practice I think I landed a pop
shuvit once so after a while I got bored
of doing the tricks and I just never
touched the skateboard again so I saw
this video recently about Tony Hawk
where he's asking people to do kick
flips what's up dude kickflip yeah ok
clip I realized that I never fulfilled
my dream of actually doing a kickflip Oh
since I was in eighth grade I've
actually picked up a lot more board
sports I got really into long boarding I
got really into snowboarding I now have
a 1 wheel I've got like almost 5000
miles under my belt one wheeling I am
challenging myself to be able to learn
how to do a kickflip in just a single
weekend from me having a skateboard to
being able to do a kickflip I don't know
how long it takes an average person to
learn how to do a kickflip I hope I can
actually do it but there's a decent
chance I'm gonna fail and not be ready
in time I don't even have a skateboard
anymore so now we're on our way to LA
skate Co it's actually buy myself a new
skateboard these guys will be able to
build me a board too specifically my
needs under $100 I don't wanna break the
board or the budget I've never been able
to actually land a kickflip is that like
a stupid unrealistic goal or is that
doable I probably couldn't do it ok
these trucks these we please bearings in
this blank for 82 bucks that's less than
100 now he's gonna build it for me
you know damn
[Music]
alright you'll get it that's what
determination is if you don't succeed
try try try out best of luck thank you
so much
let's try try right here
[Music]
twisted my ankle do oh this is gonna be
a journey so I need to actually be
taught how to do a kickflip and for that
we brought in the Sun two boards all
right Brett I need your help teaching me
how to do a kickflip okay oh okay do you
know how to all I do I think so I'm
pretty sure I can do a nollie okay you
and your hydro pops up I landed a pop
shuvit in the grass like 15 years ago
cool you land those two tricks that you
can do a kickflip no doubt so you can do
it in a weekend how did you learn when
did you learn how long did it take you
to learn if I took like two and a half
years after I started skating like
granted they were like there was nothing
like no clips on the internet or
anything like that sorry I wasn't
listening after you said it took you two
and a half years it took a while but
honestly it's it there's a lot of
physics to it which I think he would
understand oh did you get a board
already though I did get a board you
want to see it yeah
I wanted something that was decent
enough but not super cheap so this whole
setup
cost about $80
I skate them for different reasons this
when I skate morph like bird because
it's a lot wider obviously this one I
skate more for like Street stuff I've
already watched a few tutorials from
Braille skateboarding are you familiar
with that YouTube channel I am they're
actually really good
his most recent kickflip tutorial
literally came out yesterday all of the
videos they basically said learn how to
do all these other tricks first gonna do
some lollies so the other tricks that
they want us to do before doing a
kickflip is pop shuvit I'm gonna try a
pop shuvit
[Music]
the road
tap that I mean we paved some we fixed
some of it that's big clear there give
me a magnifying glass
all right this is Wren time we're gonna
focus on rim I'm just uh I'm just gonna
do an ollie define an ollie
I will slam my rear ankle down as I lift
my front foot up flick the the top of
this here underneath me the whole time
I'm lifting my back foot up again to
bring them up you wanna stay forward
that was a nice ollie
okay that was good that's pretty good
actually
okay so you got the are basically
pushing your front foot forward so
you're giving that you're giving it that
pop and then when your front foot
presses forward you're just giving it
that slide show in your feet Ke$ha
let's call the students up in person and
they ever see on YouTube videos perfect
you got it yeah I don't think it's
impossible for you to learn in order for
me to really learn a little bit better
about the mechanics behind foot
placement all that I wanted to do
something that we can all really do this
week which is to put you into a motion
capture suit capture your actual motion
data if you do in a kickflip so that I
can analyze that think if I watch your
motion capture data that might help sure
yeah what we do can okay that's good
yeah so what are you guys looking for
technique roll camera roll recording
step on the skateboard kickflip
excellent right thank you so much for
doing this you keep doing it keep
skating
all right so man it's always a good day
when breakfast y-yeah he left with the
suit and my board thank you
gosh thinking he was gonna leave with my
board suit though oh dang so the
advantage of using a motion capture suit
is now I can actually replay this
kickflip over and over and over again
for 10,000 times if I wanted to and I
don't burn bread out the more tools you
have the better off you are at learning
is that a 7:00 in the morning and I
don't want to disturb people with my
clock to clacking breasts sent over a
video last night of Tony Hawk teaching
people how to do a kickflip and even
they struggled with it and they had 18
years of experience with it at that
point so I'm gonna go find somewhere a
little bit more remote to practice this
morning I'm on top of a mountain and I
wanted to talk to you today about Ottawa
so I've been watching kickflip tutorials
I've been talking to Bret I've been
trying to practice on my own but I also
decided you know what I gotta take this
a level outside of what I'm doing right
now and try to see if there are ways
that I can learn better
I literally have dozens of books I'd
like to recommend but I thought I should
try to recommend something a little
relevant to today's video so instead of
a fantasy or sci-fi novel I wanted to
recommend the art of learning by Josh
Waitzkin he's a chess champion by the
age of 9 and a few years later you
decided to become a Taichi champion like
you do and he realized that he's not
necessarily good at chess or Tai Chi
what he's good at is learning and so he
wrote this whole book on how to learn
audible is a service that I literally
use all the time and if you want to get
your first book for free plus two
audible originals when you try audible
for 30 days visit audible.com slash
corridor crew or you can text cord our
crew to 500 500
also has a lot of original content too
called audible originals which are
exclusive audio titles created by
celebrated storytellers from world as a
diverse as theater journalism and
literature yes but if you want to get
your first audio book for free just go
to audible.com slash corridor crew or
text corridor cruises 500 500 when you
try audible for 30 days it's great
service I use it every single month I
probably listen to about 60 hours a
month of audiobook content okay let's
get back to some kickflips
[Applause]
[Applause]
very thirsty I always have water I'm
definitely in that trough of regret
right now coming up with the idea for
this video cuz I thought I'd be
challenging but I didn't realize it'd be
impossible
that's what determination is if you
don't succeed try try try over this
gates and I would say I'm having the
wrong attitude right now I got to have
determination he's right
nowhere close to landing the trick but
for the first time I actually have the
board rotating the way it should be it's
all about getting that flick right I
feel like I know how I should be doing
it but getting my body to actually do
what I want it to do is a different
story
[Music]
[Music]
god I really hope I get this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
tutorials I've watched Mayall's you say
too when you're trying to do the flip
actually land with your front foot on
the board but your back foot on the
ground so I've been I've been practicing
for a few hours today and I feel like
I'm making no progress I'm definitely
starting to believe that this was a
fool's errand but it's been a good
Saturday hanging out I know like
technically what I need to do well my
body's not doing it and I don't know
what I'm doing wrong so I'm gonna bring
Brett back to see if he can actually
identify what I'm doing wrong
I went from basically never having done
a pop shuvit to after a few tries he
coached me how to do it
so I'm hoping that maybe with a little
bit more practice I'll know what to do
for doing a kickflip and with his
tutoring I'll actually be able to land
it so it's actually kind of hard to set
up cameras for all these tries so for
the rest of today I'm not gonna do any
more camera work
[Music]
[Music]
what up sign it's what you have when
you're Lin
yes and stuff on your lens here so
you've got 48 hours no from right now I
got less than a day so let's see what
you got so far
there you go I'll do it
hop in it right when you fill that pot
once you pop just jump up a little
really come down the knees come up like
I'm trying to light a match
[Music]
[Music]
I think I overestimated my ability to
learn how to do this I was hoping to
skip the line and go straight to the
front and it turns out that I can't
really do that I really do have to
divide my time in line you know really
mastering the ollie
really getting the pop shuvit down
getting a better feel for just riding
the board in general like you're saying
I'm close but it doesn't matter because
I'm not there how long did you spend
though yeah how long like all together
deep like you're on your board out of 48
hours you gave your stuff 48 hours right
out of those 48 hours how long do you
feel like you actually we've only been
on for three hours today it seems like
forever I think I spent about three
hours yesterday so six hours total
so no throw in another hour I did I did
some little over seven yeah seven hours
best seven hours so far on the board
trying to do the kickflip that's not
even remotely enough to to learn any
skill that's complex like this at least
Avengers was good I don't saw a good
superhero movie I do really appreciate
you can you chorus man you almost have
it
my expectation to do this in the weekend
was completely unreasonable
so yeah miss Allen heard of you could
definitely do it but just can't watch
adventurous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's so close landing this that's a
lot of like eanes
get like one trick right yeah oh my god
my shins are beat up right now they are
bloody my foot when I laid it on my foot
I've got I could feel the bruise so I
had a for eight hours how long would you
say that you spin on it and how long
would you say eight eight hours from
what was just like I finally got to a
par I was able to identify those three
things it's the pop the flick in the
legs working together like it did yeah
I'm spicata of injunction there you go
guys mode this guy I did it good job
thank you son now I'm gonna go home and
get some sleep
yeah cuz you gotta get up at 4:00 a.m. I
do 350 AMC's
there you go that's what determination
is if you don't succeed try try try but
that was that was the actual legit one
it's super messy it's super janky but I
will take it doesn't matter dude I sleep
some vowels forever over and over again
because I've landed it doesn't mean I
know how to do it I'm not the best
teacher either some believe it great huh
did you did great you thought I wouldn't
have been able to do this without you
no you would have though they would have
taken me so much longer I've watched the
accounts from people online I've read
descriptions on how to do it none of
that compares to having a one-on-one
tutor who can recognize what you're
doing wrong and help you correct that
because otherwise I'm just maybe making
bad habits oh I'm trying to give her to
you sir clear sir Oh what are you
suppose he's thinking about right now at
this very minute
[Music]